hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching edward last week for
Tamra's never seen i watched
plan 9 from outer space with a bunch of
friends it was really fun i had never
heard of edwin in my entire life ever
not once literally have not even heard
the name Ed Wood and it's a Tim Burton
movie how did I miss this I'm excited to
see the casting choices to see how much
everybody looks like the original
characters and how well they do there
I'm just very excited I think it's gonna
be great
I'm very fun to see it I really enjoy
Tim Burton especially the earlier works
of Tim Burton so I'm just I'm just
excited yeah alright let's get it
[Music]
that was so engaging that was so flippin
good I think this is my favorite Johnny
Depp performance of all time he's always
just been very like mad to me I guess I
haven't seen him in in his like very
early works and I think that's where I'm
missing his genius why everyone just
loves him so much I honestly I could I
could really just give her take it away
I just I don't care about his acting
very much it it always kind of puts me
off this was so different from what I
always see him doing and I loved it I
thought it was very weird to see Sarah
Jessica Parker in this role I don't know
that I've ever seen her act before I
didn't watch Sex in the City
I've watched a couple episodes it's not
for me you guys have seen me not
enjoying Bill Murray and quite a few
films in this series this is my absolute
favorite Bill Murray movie of all time
and Ike will agree with me he was sassy
in a way that I always want him to be
sassy I always want him to be like like
a little sassy but for me
his comedy usually reads just kind of
jerk sassy which isn't my thing I know
almost everyone does not agree with me
there but I usually am NOT a fan of its
comedy and I know that's crazy thing I
know everyone loves to me so beloved but
this was perfect for him I loved the
amount of who was on screen I loved his
comedy everything played really funny
and I super believed him I honestly
can't believe how much I want to
research and and and I just know more
about Edie wood and wood is a
fascinating person well I had no idea
about him being interested in wearing
women's clothing and making a movie
about it
and really narrowing it down getting
down to it if you haven't seen Atwood is
it's the disaster artist of the 90s and
it's done so well it's the story of Ed
Wood who is a
interesting filmmaker and director and
actor and writer and him meeting bela
lugosi who is the famous dracula actor
but meeting him at the end of his career
where he's not getting passed anymore a
story of like the mishaps that happened
throughout that and he's kind of like
ragtag group of friends he he gets in
and kind of how he finagle since his way
into getting money in and getting you
know funded for these giant projects I
endured the actors who played Vampira
and her whole story about how she sued
Elvira after the fact when Elvira kind
of stole her act and it was unsuccessful
which is a bummer you feel for me feel
for Bella you feel for Atwood you feel
for the girlfriends of Ed Wood mm not so
much Sarah Jessica Parker obviously but
you just it's it's just full of heart
it's really well done the shots are all
very interesting it looks beautiful and
odd in a way that you want from Tim
Burton but that's not like too much that
you know so Ed Wood Johnny Depp has a
line where he says I'm just scared it's
not gonna get any better than this and
the way that he delivered it and just
those words really ring true to me like
very much and I just my mouth dropped
open I'm saying oh wow
same-same Edwards same I very much
identified with that it was beautiful so
there was a lot of moments in the film
where I felt like oh man I feel for you
so much especially watching a bill about
film being made and watching a film
about acting and and the creative
process and just like the sad rejections
that you get real rejections that like
affect you like
with actual money and like actual jobs
and it it very much is something that if
you're in real entertainment you
understands you find out in the film
that Bela Lugosi is addicted to morphine
something that you shoot at your arm
with and it was sad and you know also
you know relatable now that I do
morphine or heroin but it's just
relatable to see someone struggling and
dealing with being forgotten and and and
it just it was beautiful but when
watching plan 9 I thought that Bela
Lugosi died after like a couple days of
shooting but I think what they showed in
Ed Wood is that he died before they had
even written the script there was just
some random footage of Bela that they
used in this is why in plan 9 you see
the same shot being used over and over
and over again and such an emphasis put
on that first scene with him looking at
the roses and his wife is dead watching
the process of making plan nine was so
interesting to see this love of this man
and this love of all the work that he
put out and turning like this much
footage into a movie it was quite a
movie but nonetheless very interesting
the film is such a lovely delight but
ultimately it's just it's very sad it's
fascinating and it's it's heartbreaking
it's wonderful storytelling so so Sagi
field for ed and you feel for the people
who surrounds him and and he's so he's
so passionate the passion only gets you
so far in this case I mean passion got
him to have like one of the most famous
cult films of all time so got him pretty
fired but you know what I mean it you
know when he was living it only really
got him so far and the people that
surrounded him we're just kind of this
ragtag group of misfits who
he used and loved and because he was one
himself and I just really loved that I
love that I'm pretty sure this got the
least amount of predictions I've ever
received on Twitter so I don't know how
well this episode was gonna do maybe
it's just for me maybe this one was just
for me you will be surprised how good
Johnny Depp is in this movie yeah
like I said he doesn't do it for me
usually I think he has really settled
into this bizarre drunk pirate that he
does for every film and usually in films
I'm not looking for a bizarre drunk
pirate you know I'm just looking for a
human that you can connect with and you
can connect with him here easily the
most slept on Burton Depp collab a
hundred percent agree a hundred percent
agree you'll think Johnny Depp is so
good and you'll forget his Johnny Depp
also the tentacle scene gold yes I did
forget it was Johnny Depp and that's
what I want out of a Johnny Depp movie
to forget that he's there and that
tension we'll see was amazing he's a
soul of that after the tentacle seen
edward goes up to bella and is like i'm
sorry i should not be asking someone
like you who i respect so much to call a
friend to get in cold water and wrestle
a dead octopus at 4:00 a.m. and i'm
really sorry about that
and Bella's like i wouldn't do it for
many people and you just see their
beautiful friendship and man I loved it
I loved it you will relate to Ed's
friends the outcasts yes I think that's
why this film resonated with me so much
is that I really related to Ed's story
and Ed's friends
is just the sadness and ultimate
heartbreak that is entertainment and I
don't know I think that's sad to say
that I it's such a it's such a job that
if there was any other option for you
you would just do that other option
because it sucks and it's terrible and
amazing and passionate and just exciting
but also devastating the lows are so low
and the highs are so high and you know
it's entertainment and that's what it is
and so they really were able to raise
aliy capture that in such a way that you
really identify with and I just man I
loved it yes yep
serving my serving my best Vampira look
millennial Vampira thank you so much for
watching everyone I am coming at ya next
week
the jurat spot two lost worlds lost
world the first Jurassic Park was my
second episode ever for this series and
I've seen the third dress apart from
multiple times never seen the second I'm
very excited to jump in and watch that
and I hope that I will see you there
thanks so much for watching see you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you